[موسيقى]
هذه الحمله الدعائيه استخدمت روسيا لغه
التذكير بالاستعمار حيث انما يمس هذه
الدول الافريقيه هو استذكار حقبه
الاستعمار وبالتالي ما نشهده هو ارتباط
هذه الدول الافريقيه بهذا الخطاب المضاد
للغرب خاصه مع وجود بعض الفصائل المسلحه
في بعض هذه الدول الافريقيه مثل مالي
وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وفي بوركينا فاسو
التي بدات تنتفض ضد انظمتها ولتعزيز قواهم
يلجاون لمثل هذه الجماعات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
على مدى السنوات الاخيره كانت معظم
العمليات في منطقه الساحل ضد التنظيمات
الارهابيه مخصصه فقط لمكافحه الارهاب ولم
تكن سياسه طويله الامد كما لم نشهد تحولا
كبيرا من حيث خفض الوجود الارهابي في
منطقه الساحل وهذه الجماعات الارهابيه
ستبقى نشطه وفاعله في المنطقه مستخدمه
علاقاتها لمواصله عملياتها وكسب التاييد
[موسيقى]
ليس لدينا وجود عسكري روسي هنا بالتالي
تبقى هذه التنظيمات الارهابيه محافظه على
عدم استخدام لغه ان القوات الروسيه هي
قوات المستعمره الغازيه بل يتحدثون عن
المزايا العسكريه للوجود الروسي ولا اظن
اننا سنرى اثرا يذكر لذلك على عمليات
التنظيمات الارهابيه لطالما كانت هناك
عمليات لمكافحه الارهاب
[موسيقى]